LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgenen mutuel santé prévoyance
présente état de
[Musique]
santé
plus de la moitié des Français a eu mal
au dos au moins une fois au cours des 12
derniers mois pourtant ces douleurs font
encore l'objet d'idée reçu 45 % des
Français considèrent par exemple que le
meilleur remède est le
repos je sens paradoxalement que les
pompes que j'aurais jamais imaginé être
un mouvement qui pouvait m'aider par
rapport j'avais bah mettre petit à petit
ça j'ai du mal à comprendre la
mécanique les mauvais réflexes
augmentent le risque de voir les
douleurs s'installer et devenir
chronique pour les médecins il est donc
nécessaire d'aborder ce mal du siècle
dans toute sa complexité afin de mieux
le prendre en charge on peut pas dire
des choses comme j'ai plus de j'ai entre
45 et 60 ans j'ai mal au dos à telle
hauteur et ça me fait mal au ha en bas
et donc pour tout le monde on va d'abord
faire ça et si ça marche pas en B père
ces choses-là n'existent pas en douleur
du dos et en fait le traitement se guide
de manière très personnalisée mal de dos
halte aux idées reçues c'est le thème de
ce nouveau numéro d'état de
[Musique]
santé bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
état de santé une émission consacrée au
fameux mal du siècle mal de dos il y a 1
et une façon de souffrir physique
psychologique des vertèbres déplacées
des douleurs lombaires un tour de d
autant éviter les idées reçues tout de
même bonjour à vous Aurore mambriani on
va les passer en vue c'est important
parce que effectivement tout le monde a
des histoires de mal de dos pratiquement
dans sa vie vous êtes kinésithérapeute
je parlais par exemple de vertèbres
déplacé est-ce que ça c'est une
appellation une formulation qui est
conforme à la
réalité pas vraiment on peut pas dire ça
non les vertèbles ne se déplacent pas ou
alors quand elles se déplacent
malheureusement c'est très grave et
c'est une urgence mais quand on va chez
le kinésithérapeute et qu'on a mal au
dos ou chez le médecin c'est rarement
une vertable qui est déplacée alors
certaines personnes qui se font
manipuler entendent bien des os alors
que ce soit des vertèbres d'ailleurs ou
ou d'autres éléments du dos qui font
pardon jeis pas comment le dire ça fait
craque quand même donc on se dit alors
là elle a replacé la vertèbre vertèbre
cervicale c'est pas ça c'est pas une
vertèbre qui est reprèslassé c'est ce
qu'on appelle un pH phomène de
cavitation donc il y a du gaz dans
l'articulation et on peut écarter un
petit peu les surfaces articulaires et
on a une petite bulle de gaz qui se
développe se déplace qui fait un petit
plop qui est perceptible souvent ça le
craque c'est un plop c'est plutôt un
plop qu'un crac ou qui craque et et donc
pourquoi c'est important de bien nommer
les choses parce que c'est important que
les patients n'aient pas de faux schéma
dans la tête parce que en fait ça peut
amener des croyances sur la gravité et
les les enferm aussi eux-mêmes dans un
cercle vicieux et le fait d'avoir peur
ils vont limiter leur mouvement et ce
cette limitation du mouvement et cette
peur de bouger ça peut être un facteur
de chronicisation notamment sur les
douleurs lombaires c'est important de
repasser et de passer en revue les idées
reçues et on va tout de suite regarder
votre
[Musique]
parcours aurore mambriani est
kinésithérapeute elle est la présidente
en France de l'association OMT qui
regroupe des kinés spécialisés dans la
rééducation des troubles
musculos-squeltiques comme les
lombalgies des troubles cororand briani
connaît particulièrement bien car elle a
exercé pendant 10 ans dans son cabinet
libéral en Haute Marne auprès d'une
patientelle ouvrière et
[Musique]
agricole alorsore mambriani il y a plein
de noms pour qualifier le mal de dos
j'en ai passé quelquesuns vu est-ce
qu'il y a pas un terme générique la
lombalgie par exemple est-ce que ça
concerne toutes les douleurs de dos non
la lombalgie c'est pour la région
lombaire donc le bas du dos ouais c'est
ça le bas du dos ensuite on a la région
thoracique la région cervicale donc on
peut avoir la lombalgie la cervicalg
c'est ce qu'on a de plus commun sur les
MUXs de dos effectivement à part dire
douleur de dos ou mux de dos c'est
difficile parce que si on utilise
d'autres termes après on induit d'autres
choses par exemple des causes ou des
conséquences donc on peut dire qu'on a
des des douleurs ou ou des motes d'eau
et demander à son kiné par exemple de
savoir exactement de quoi rourne il
s'agit deuxème idée reçue très
importante c'est que quand on a mal au
dos on s'immobilise on s'allonge et on
se dit que ça ira mieux c'est vraiment
alors là quelque chose qui est
extraordinairement répandu est-ce qu'on
a raison alors si on a des grosses
douleurs de dos sûrement qu'il y a
plusieurs facteurs qui jouent de toute
façon il y a plusieurs facturs qui joue
et il peut y avoir un facteur de fatigue
donc si on est fatigué il faut se
reposer mais pour la douleur de dos en
elle-même le repos ne va pas améliorer
les choses c'està-dire que au au-delà de
un jour ou d'autre de repos c'est
déconseillé et il faut reprendre les
activités donc ce qu'on disait avant où
il faut rester par exemple 3 mois à
l'ité ça c'est pire ça empire ça amène
un enridissement articulaire ça entraîne
le fait que les muscles sont moins actif
donc ça veut dire que le le travail en
plus pour reprendre une activité normale
va être plus long donc un à de jours de
repos mais pas plus ça c'est passionnant
on en parlera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
avec le reportage de Marianne cazou
troème idée reçue porter des charges
lourdes ça donne mal au dos vrai ou faux
alors tout est une question de contexte
mais che quelqu'un qui est entraîné il y
a pas de raison que ça fasse mal au dos
en fait entraîner c'est-à-dire et ben
c'est comme avec le sport si vous
demandez à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
couru de faire un marathon du jour au
lendemain il va avoir mal partout mal
aux jambes et tout ça quelqu'un qui ne
porte jamais de charge lourde si vous
lui demandez du jour au lendemain de
faire un déménagement avec des morceaux
d'armoire ça va être compliqué mais
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude de faire ça
où son corps est entraîné pour ça ça va
pas lui poser de problème en fait
néanmoins la question du
travail facteur de mal de dos est quand
même une question très présente dans le
monde professionnel c'est un enjeu de de
santé publique la preuve en quelques
chiffres
[Musique]
infographie le mal de dos au travail
presque tout le monde connaît ça en
France plus de qu actifs sur 5 déclarent
en avoir déjà souffert et mal prévenir
les lombalie a un coût important pour la
société arrêtons-nous donc sur ces
chiffres le mal de dos représente 20 %
des accident du travail et des maladies
professionnelles et un/ers des arrêts de
travail de plus de 6
mois en 2017 par exemple 12 millions de
journées de travail ont ainsi été perdu
soit un coup de 61 millions d'euros pour
l'assurance maladie et plus d'un
milliard d'euros supporté par les
entreprises sous forme de cotisation une
étude suédoise a montré que 85 % du coût
de la lombalgie chronique par patient
était lié à cette perte de productivité
au travail concluant qu'une meilleure
prise en charge permet de faire des
économies même avec les traitements les
plus coûteux quant aux employeurs en
font-ils assez 69 % des salariés
français ont le sentiment d'être mal
accompagné dans la prévention du mal de
dos les actions menées jusqu'à
maintenant n'ont pas fait baisser la
fréquence ni la durée des arrêts de
travail les formes chroniques qui sont
les plus invalidantes ont même plutôt
tendance à
[Musique]
augmenter
Aurore mambriani on passe en revue on le
rappelle dans cette émission toutes les
idées reçues relatives au mal de dos on
dit souvent quand quelqu'un a mal au dos
c'est psychologique on dit mais parce
que tu es nerveux parce que tu es
stressé le stress est un énorme facteur
de de mal de dos donc on dit voilà
qu'est-ce qui va pas dans ta tête pour
que tu a mal de le dos est-ce que c'est
une question pertinente la question
pertinente c'est de savoir si la
personne a mal au dos quels sont tous
les déterminants qui jouent sur son mal
de dos donc le stress effectivement peut
être un facteur comme le fait d'être
contrarié par une situation
conflictuelle au travail ou dans le
cercle familial ou dans un cercle amical
tout tout ça peut jouer sur le mal de
dos ou et sil faut aller chez kiné ou
chez le psy les les kiné ils peuvent
savoir détecter quelle est cette part
psychologique et réorienté vers
quelqu'un mais souvent il y a pas que un
facteur donc ce qui est intéressant en
fait c'est d'avoir une approche qui est
pluripressionnelle c'est-à-dire qu'on
voit le kiné pour certaines choses on
voit le psychologue pour d'autres choses
des fois on voit une assistante sociale
des fois on voit d'autres thérapeutes un
nutritionniste ou ou un professeur de
sport qui va travailler sur des
exercices plus spécifiques et justement
professeur de sport
qui fait bouger son patient quand il a
mal au dos c'est contreintuitif comme on
dit on on ne pensait pas à cela il y a a
je ne sais pas il y a quelques dizaines
d'années au contraire comment le
mouvement peut-il soulager les douleurs
c'est un reportage signé Marianne
[Musique]
Cazo contrairement à une idée reçue
encore très répandue face au mal de dos
il faut bouger salut Étienne ça va ça va
ça va depuis qu'il est suivi dans ce
cabinet de kinésithérapie pour sa lombe
j Étienne Marchall l'a bien compris ok
alors donc tu m'as dit là tu as réussi à
faire ce qu'on avait convenu ouais tout
ce qu'on avait convenu un peu plus par
il n'avait jamais été autant encouragé à
bouger pour soulager ses douleurs je
sens paradoxalement que les pompes que
j'aurais jamais imaginé être un
mouvement qui pouvait m'aider par
rapport au douleurs que j'avais bah
mettre petit à petit ça j'ai du mal à
comprendre la mécanique regarde si je
prends ton coude et que je te laisse
comme ça pendant 3h qu'est-ce qui va se
passer d'un moment bah je vais être
complètement De Lor En kilos ouais ça va
s'quiloser ça va faire mal et ceera et
qu'est-ce que tu vas vouloir faire tu
vas vouloir tu vas tu vas VO le temp il
y a un peu il y a un peu ce côtélà avec
avec le dos c'est-à-dire que c'est tirer
vers l'arrière ouou grandir ou autre
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait
souvent on a plutôt tendance à être un
peu tout le temps comme ça surtout quand
on a un métier où on est on est tout le
temps devant l'ordi pendant ces longs
mois de douleur Étienne Marchall a peu
sollicité ses muscles d'orceau qu'il
renforce aujourd'hui et même ces
mouvements qui ne cibleent pas le dos
ont un impact sur la lombalgie et hop tu
montes je relève en montant et tu
changes et c'est parti ettienne Marchall
pour aller refaire chez lui en fait la
douleur c'est un signalalarme par exle
si tu mets la main sur le feu tu vas
avir l'alarme qui va arriver pour te
dire enlève ta main parce que tu vas te
brûler en gros Grosso c'est ça et le
signal à larme comme tout signal il peut
se régler plus sensible moins sensible
et plus il est réglé sensible plus bah
la douleur peut se déclencher facilement
pour des trucs qui sont anodins et
l'activité physique on sait que c'est un
excellent moyen enfin il y a pas que
celui-là mais c'est un des moyens qu'on
a qui permet de régler correctement le
signal à l'inverse trop de repos
augmente le risque de voir les douleurs
s'installer c'est ce qui est arrivé à
Sylvie Bouchard après une chute en VTT
elle est restée près de 20 ans
immobilisée dans un corset pour traiter
sa lombalgie chronique elle pensait ne
jamais pouvoir remonter sur un vélo à
l'époque il existait pas les programmes
dont vous vous bénéficiez aujourd'hui
les programmes de réentraînement à
l'effort c'était bien tout le contraire
qui était recommandé c'était le repos
strict en 2010 j'en pouvais plus vous
pouvez bien le comprendre hein
psychologiquement c'était très difficile
20 ans à l'ité ça a été très très
difficile sur le plan
socio-familial sur tous les plans de la
vie à force de persévérance et de
patience elle s'est remise à bouger à
nager et enfin à pédaler les médecins
n'avaient plus rien à me proposer donc
j'avais pas le choix que que de me
prendre en main et et de me de Me
remuscler petit à petit au travers de la
douleur ça a duré 3 ans ça été très très
long mais j'y suis arrivé je vais
beaucoup mieux je prends plus de
médicament je suis plus immobilisé donc
c'est vraiment un réel message d'espoir
que je leur je leur fais passer pour
éviter à d'autres patients d'affronter
seul une telle épreuve Sylvie Bouchard a
rejoint l'équipe de ce programme
spécialisé en tant que patiente experte
un diplôme qu'elle a passé afin de faire
valoir sa connaissance fine de la
lombalgie chronque
c'est
do qui coordonne le programme bonjour
bonjour allez-y ent les patients
arrivent souvent dans ce centre de
rééducation après plusieurs années de
douleur de mise au repos et d'échecs
thérapeutique c'est bon c'est la fin je
jamais pouvoir m'en sortir parce que
vous avez essayé tellement de choses oui
c'est ça on passe de main en main en
fait et puis vous êtes un cas difficile
monsieur je sais pas quoi faire donc on
se dit mais qui va pouvoir faire quelque
chose OK et donc c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut là cette équipe
pluridisciplinaire qui va vous aider à
avancer et reprendre confiance les
patients comme Frédéric Vatier suivent
ici un réentraînement à l'effort
intensif de 4 semaines une
nécessité car à force d'éviter de bouger
par crainte d'avoir mal ils ont perdu
beaucoup de muscles et le mouvement ce
n'est pas que l'exercice physique ce
sont aussi des activités du quotidien
qu'il faut progressivement
reprendreas voilà maintenant je demandé
d'enfourner par exemple avec l'erg
thérapeute du centre Céline Nardy peut
maintenant effectuer ses gestes qu'elle
ne faisait plus
ah ben voilà peut-être parce que là il y
a pas la grille mais ouais c'est ben
voilà c'est pas mal ça
oui vous avez vu vous avez encadré la
porte oui vous êtes pas de face face
j'aime beaucoup faire la pâtisserie avec
mes enfants et tout ce qui était atelier
pâtisserie jusqu'à l'heure actuelle je
ne les faisais plus c'est imp la vie
familiale parce que il y a plein de
choses qu'on ne peut plus faire qu'on
s'interdit de faire parce queon pense
que la douleur fait ben faut arrêter et
après pour se remettre en route toute
seule ben c'est pas possible ici bien
accompagné elle retrouve son autonomie
et la force de sortir du cercle vicieux
de la douleur tout ça avec le
[Musique]
mouvement AORE MRI est-ce qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de patients qui sont
étonnés si vousz leur demander de faire
du sport alors qu'ils ont mal au dos il
y a beaucoup de patients qui viennent en
avoir une autre réponse que faire des
mouvements estce qu'on parle pas
forcément de faire de sport parce que
faire du sport tout de suite on a l'idée
de de transpirer un peu de compétition
de choses un peu difficiles et en plus
des gens des fois les gens se retrouvent
plus dans le fait d'avoir une activité
simple qui s'apparente pas forcément à
du sport et par exemple le jardinage ça
peut être une activité aussi qui peut
qu'on ne doit pas s'interdire si on a
mal au dos ouais c'est ça idée reçu la
natation c'est bon pour le dos vrai ou
faux ah bah c'est bon chez les gens qui
aiment la
natation et donc c'est bon pour le dos
éventuellement ça peut être bon pour les
gens qui aiment la natation les gens qui
n'aiment pas la natation il faut pas
leur dire faites de la natation ça va
être bon pour votre dos parce qu'en fait
ils vont y aller une fois sous euh sous
la contrainte parce que le médecin leur
a dit ça mais en fait ils aiment pas y
aller et du coup ils vont jamais y
retourner et en fait c'est pas ça qu'on
cherche ce qu'on cherche c'est que les
gens bougent un petit peu plus et quand
on propose une activité on demande aux
gens qu'est-ce qu'ils aime faire parce
que l'idée c'est qu'il le garde dans le
temps alors autre idée reçue il faut se
tenir droit on aura moins mal au au dos
ce qui est embêtant dans cette idée de
de c'est le un peu le tienstoi droit
qu'on dit aux adolescentsou parce que
les ados ils sont un peu tout le temps
comme ça on dit ouais c'est ça et on
leur dit tiens-toi droit alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils se redressent comme ça
d'un coup ils prennent une position
qu'ils ne prennent jamais donc déjà leur
corps n'a pas l'habitude ils le font
vite et en plus leurs muscles sont pas
entraînés à tenir cette position donc à
un moment ils vont dire mais non mais si
je me tiens droit ça me fait mal au dos
et en fait je suis mieux quand je suis
comme ça donc par exemple pour les
adolescents ce qui est important c'est
que en contrepartie dans dans une autre
partie de la journée de la semaine il y
ait d'autres activités qui fassent par
exemple du basket du volet ou une
activité physique qui fait que leur dos
va prendre les autres positions et les
emmagasiner autant que la position en
avant donc ne pas forcément dire à ces
enfants de se tenir droit alors en fait
plutôt que de dire à ses enfants
tiens-toi droit parce qu'il reste toute
la journée dans le canapé il vaut mieux
l'envoyer dehors et puis qu'il aille se
balader en fait intéressant cette
approche globale que vous avez alors
autre question on a une jambe plus
longue que l'autre on a des pieds plats
on est on est
cambré c'est pour ça qu'on a mal au dos
non non non non on a tous une une
différence d'à peu près 1 cm ou 1 cm dem
des des jambes ça ça ne pose aucun souci
et tout ce qui est pied plat ou dos
cambré en fait on a un corps humain qui
s'adapte depuis la naissance donc sauf
si on a les pieds plats après un
accident ou un traumatisme ou une
cambrure de dos qui change après un
traumatisme en fait le corps grandit
comme ça depuis la naissance donc il a
pas de de raison particulière je ne sais
pas si c'était une idée reçue du corps
médical pendant des des décennies mais
très longtemps mal de dos répété
évidemment sur une longue distance
vousous entendait une opération c'est un
petit peu moins vrai aujourd'hui
Marianne Cazo est allée à lillele pour
comprendre dans quel contexte on prenait
ou pas la décision d'opérer
[Musique]
reportage dans 90 % des cas les douleurs
lombaires disparaissent d'elles-même au
bout de 4 semaines mais parfois elle
persiste une question se pose alors
faut-il
opérer à la ligne découverte forttuite
d'une ectasie de l'orte thoracique
ascendante à 38 mm moins de 5 mm
d'épaisseur point il n'y a pas
d'indication à une réévaluation
systématique par
imagerie conformément aux
recommandations actuelles point une
question à laquelle Jean-François budzic
n'aime pas répondre car à la différence
de cette pathologie cardio-vasculaire
les lombalgies sont trop complexes pour
être catégorique on peut pas dire des
choses comme j'ai plus de j'ai entre 45
et 60 ans j'ai mal au dos à telle
hauteur et ça me fait mal en ha en bas
et donc pour tout le monde on va d'abord
faire ça et si ça marche pas on mopère
ces choseslà n'existent pas en douleur
du dos et en fait le traitement se guide
de manière très personnalisée avec ces
douleurs si particulières le radiologue
a appris à ne pas toujours se fier à
l'imagerie pour choisir un traitement
adapté prenons l'exemple de cette
patiente pour laquelle il a mené
l'enquête d'une dame qui a 80 ans qui a
dressé pour faire un certain type
d'infiltration de la colonne pour une
pathologie qu'on appelle un canal
lombaire rétréci autrement dit ces Ners
sont serrés au niveau de la colonne
vertébrale comme le prouve cette image
une pathologie qui se manifeste par des
douleurs nerveuses dans les jambes mais
dans ce cas précis elle a une mal dos
mais elle a pas du tout de douleur dans
les jambes ce qui montre que l'image
qu'on voit ici même si elle est
impressionnante n'est pas la cause des
symptômes le traitement peut se
concentrer là-dessus et vite tomber en
échec puisqu'il est fort probable que
l'infiltration de ces ner n'a pas grand
intérêt et par contre en allant chercher
une approche personnalisée on revoit les
images on adapte les choses autrement en
allant chercher en fait le coupable qui
est juste à côté du suspect principal
qui pour le coup est complètement
innocent ne s'intéressz qu'à l'imagerie
médicale peut donc induire en erreur il
faut un interrogatoire fouillé pour
trouver le traitement
adéquat c'est plutôt ici devant sur le
côté derrière non derrière c'est plus
rare plus devant devant ou sur le côté
très bien vous faites quoi dans la vie
madame je suis ouvrière textile très
bien donc vous êtes amené à rester
debout je supposeant 8 et éventuellement
à porter des charges très bien vous
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
traitement du point de vue des douleurs
en fait j'ai j'ai mal chaque jour j'ai
mal mais il y a vraiment des moment o je
souffre terriblement en pleurer et donc
si déjà ça pouvait s'atténuer même
limite avoir mal mais ne plus souffrir
le choix du traitement ne dépend pas de
la lésion mais des attentes des patients
et Jean-François budzic propose d'abord
des alternative à la chirurgie comme la
radiologie interventionnelle elle se
fait au bloc mais elle est très peu
invasive la patiente est
positionné on va ensuite sur le repérage
trouver la zone et puis on va trouver
une zone qui soit Sécur donc à cet
endroitl il y a de la peau des muscles à
traverser donc c'est pas très compliqué
et puis on va raisonner aussi en
fonction des petites terminaisons
nerveuses qui sont dans le coin pour
essayer de trouver l'approche la plus
pertinente la radiologie permet de
cibler la douleur de la manière la plus
précise
possible Jean-François buz injecte un
anesthésique local puis un produit de
contraste qu'il peut suivre à
l'imagerie
voilà donc on a le produit qui a bien
diffusé dans l'espace autour voilà qui
circonscrit exactement une fois la zone
identifiée l'infiltration de produits
corticoïdes est prête voilà c'est
terminé voilà on va laisser
infuser si cela ne suffit pas à apaiser
durablement la douleur le radiologue
pourra s'y attaquer en chauffant les
nerfs par
radiofréquence pard et pour chaque
intervention ce n'est pas la lésion qui
est
ciblée information n'est peut-être dans
l'articulation mais c'est le cerveau qui
intègre tout ça avec d'autres choses et
qui crée l'information de douleur donc
l'idée ici c'est de ne pas forcément
aller chercher le par exemple une
articulation qui va être en cause mais
de s'intéresser aux symptômes qui posent
problème au malad c'est la douleur si la
cause du mal de dos est clairement
mécanique la chirurgie peut-être une
bonne solution mais elle est R
[Musique]
nécessaire alors Brian c'est vrai que il
y a beaucoup de patients à qui ont
proposé une opération et on l'a vu dans
dans le reportage il y a des
alternatives à cette opération est-ce
que c'est un progrès de la médecine euh
oui on peut dire que c'est un progrès la
médecine elle s'est conçue comme ça elle
s'est conçue sur un abord de la maladie
mais lagie c'est pas une maladie c'est
pas comme une tumeur ou c'est c'est une
affection on peut dire ouais mais c'est
pas quelque chose comme quelque chose
qu'il faudrait enlever c'est pour ça
qu'on a pensé aussi à la chirurgie la
médecine elleelle s'est construite la
sence disant si le patient a mal c'est
qu'il y a quelque chose qui
dysfonctionne dans le corps de du
patient et maintenant on sait que en
fait on peut avoir des douleurs et des
affections sans qu'il y a quelque chose
qui dysfonctionne dans le corps du
patient c'est-à-dire que il y a d'autres
facteurs qui jouent autour et qui
peuvent se manifester par des symptômes
physiques ou des choses qui se passent
au niveau du cerveau alors on va passer
des idées reçues à la la réalité de
votre pratique médicale évidemment c'est
comme pour beaucoup de de rendez-vous
médicaux c'est très long maintenant
d'avoir un rendez-vous chez le kiné et
il y a une volonté du législateur de
faire en sorte queon puisse aller
directement chez le kiné sans passer par
un généraliste alors ça c'est pas une
idée reçue c'est une mesure qui a été
adoptée on verra dans un instant vous
avez souhaité interroger un député comme
c'est la règle dans cette émission sur
cette question l'application de la loi
c'est Stéphanie Rist député renaissance
du loi qui est auteur de cette
proposition de loi et votre question
était la suivante à quel moment
pensez-vous que la loi pourra être
appliquée s'agit-il d'une première étape
vers un élargissement de la disposition
elle vous
[Musique]
répond cette loi a été votée au
printemps on devrait avoir les décrets
qui devraient sortir prochainement donc
j'espère très fortement avant la fin de
l'année j'aimerais bien sûr qu'on soit
allé un peu plus vite mais ce qui est
important c'est que tous les
kinésithérapeutes qui travaille en
exercice de soins coordonnés dans les
maisons de santé dans les centres de
santé et les malades pourront aller
directement voir ces kinés qu'il existe
par ailleurs une expérimentation dans
certains départements pour ouvrir à plus
de kinésithérapeutes et une fois que et
les patients et les professionnels
seront verront que la sécurité du malade
se fait sans aucun problème on pourra
discuter d'un élargissement à tous les
les kinésithérapeutes mais l'important
est quand même de garder le soin
coordonné puisque le parcours du patient
il faut qu'il soit respecté il faut que
les professionnels de santé travaillent
ensemble c'est vraiment majeur à mon
avis sur la qualité de prise en charge
des
[Musique]
malades alors on a compris que la loi
quand elle sera appliquée ne concernera
qu'une petite partie des médecins Vous
vous l'aviez évalué à 3 % vous voudriez
que ça soit élargi à tout le monde le
plus vite possible pour les patient ce
serait bien que l'élargissement soit
plus important effectivement mais cet
accès direct on le fait déjà un petit
peu c'est-à-dire que quand on suit un
patient pour une lombalgie par exemple
et qui vient nous voir le lundi en nous
disant bon le dos ça va mais là je me
suis fait mal au poignet ce weekend
est-ce que vous pouvez regarder en fait
souvent c'est ce qu'on fait et ça c'est
aussi un petit peu de l'accès direct
passionnant de vous avoir entendu hein
je pense que vous avez remis certaines
idées en place une la dernière en
conclusion elle est très légère quoi que
est-ce que porter des talons ça fait mal
au dos euh quand vous allez un mariage
si vous mettez des grands talons vous
n'avez jamais l'habitude de mettre des
grands talons on sait ce qui se passe
casser la figure d'abord c'est un risque
mais on sait ce qui se passe au bout de
3h c'est que tout le monde enfin toutes
les femmes ont enlever leurs talons et
que elles dansent soit à pied nous soit
avec d'autres chaussures donc en fait
les gens sont quand même le cerveau dit
à un moment mais là je vais pas bien
mais on a souvent mal au pied avant
d'avoir mal au dos et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y a des femmes elles ont
porté des talons toute leur vie et si
vous les mettez à plat elles vont vous
dire mais moi je suis pas bien à plat et
il y a des femmes qui sont capables de
marcher très vite avec des très haut
talons très fins c'est leur habitude
leur c'est habitué comme ça elles elles
sont comme ça elles aiment ça et elles
ont pas forcément mal au dos il n'y a
pas de modèle il y a pas de modèle dans
dans la façon de prendre en charge le
mal de dos c'est ce que je retiens de
cette émission aussi avec vous il y a
pas de modèle et non parce qu'on a AFF
faire à de l'humain et l'humain c'est
complexe merci infiniment nous avoir
accompagné dans ce numéro d'état de
santé et merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à très vite
[Musique]
pl
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuel santé prévoyance vous a
présenté état de
santé